[Music]
hey whoa jakey news t green here The
Iceman people come a nice man he's very
nice I'm moving up in the world got
third I got 30 G's around my neck let's
talk about oil prices today baby this is
cuz melted ice you know well it's liquid
ice you know why cuz it was never ice
they sure it was only bottle at room
temp it came from the mountains of
hookah sucker look that's that guy who
Kazakh it gets cold okay
I'll give it to you I'll give it to you
okay so who knows about that how oil
just went the price of oil prevail just
went so low that it crashed under zero
per barrel it's negative negative far in
the negative only go more negative not
canola oil and not vegetable oil some
people are confused
so can we can we go to the gas station
and get money back for pumping gas yeah
negative oil when they call it the price
of oil is the future price of oil all
right so it's not the current price cuz
he set prices for what they will buy it
for sell it for next month what they
speculate on what the price will be
based on supply and demand and where
they'd see it so it's not the actual
price it's based off of a price that you
promised to pay for later this if you
know a lot of people think the Jews are
behind all of it
is that wait so does that mean that in a
month from now we're gonna get paid for
coming guess like how does that work
well it's food oil to it so there's a
difference between the gas station oil
in crude oil the crude oil is just the
oil that's raw that gets pulled out of
the ground just like when do I get my
check they need to refine yes they are
there they are paying people to take the
oil off of their hands because it's more
costly for them to hold the oil so if
you have space if you're willing to just
take this container ship full of [ __ ]
millions of barrels or whatever right
it's like I saw one rose like it cost
250,000 dollars a day to like store this
oil why why like what is he doing
well they're there yeah they're movers
essentia like the person who gets mixed
oil it's not the same person who sells
the oil to the people receive it it's a
problem a middleman the middleman buys
the oil now the oil is coming and he's
like [ __ ]
there's too much even the ones oil and
all of the reserves are all full yeah
every storage is full what do I do with
it and the price kept dropping down and
no one was buying I mean where's last
time you everything guess anybody a good
year last week a month ago and honestly
same so yeah that's what I'm saying so
drive a jeeps a lot of people are in
that boat where they don't need to buy
gas right now and so oil has crashing
cars crash and then Russia and the
Saudis were in a war over who's going to
well so this is this is what's happening
because there's this whole surplus of
oil now everyone's acting like Walmart
in a way where it's like I'm gonna price
you out the business yes because right
now there's oh there's only a handful of
oil-producing nations right you have
Saudi Arabia or the Middle East and then
you have Russia
you have US China and then you have
Canada no I don't think China produces
they have the oil contracts in Iraq so
they're buying them yeah what I'm
talking about producers right right and
then for each group that I just
mentioned like they produce oil at
different cost so for example in the US
I think we're somewhere around $25 a
barrel or Canada or maybe even Russia's
around 20 but Saudi Arabia they can
produce it for ten bucks a barrel so
they can out price everybody and say
well we'll just produce more flub the
[ __ ] market price you out of the
business and then we'll come in and
we'll be the only ones that anyone can
buy all Russia said okay we're not gonna
we're pretending like that's not that
scary and we're gonna keep producing
bears little oil and then that's why
soured the Saudis we're over producing
Russia was over producing Wow nobody was
buying Cold War I said nuclear arms
beforehand and the essentially in the
Middle East they have a cartel of oil
businesses and when something like this
happens where there's a lot less
demand what they're supposed to do is
dial back how much oil to produce so
they can bring up the price again right
the problem with that there's so many
different fashions right they're like oh
yeah well totally do that what totally
will do that and then but they're like
ok you dolla back but then we'll keep
producing it and then when everything
goes back up we'll have a [ __ ] ton in
you guys we'll have less but the problem
is that they're all thinking that so
then there none of them are dialing
about they're all like yeah we'll
promise will promise and yeah and then
so then saudi arabia this is bringing it
up and then a brush is like [ __ ] you
we're not gonna back down and all this
and no one was backing out down and
that's what made the oil like crash the
market here's another conspiracy though
is that china is out here saying yes
free oil because then they can store the
[ __ ] out of this stuff and so are we yep
the US strategic oil reserve is getting
reading fulfilled through this at a
crazy cheap price because of the same
reason apparently making money from
taking oil too precisely there's so many
moving pieces to it though its way it's
still complicated and I don't even know
everything when I find hilarious though
is that he is the idea not the reality
because me and Joe been doing live shows
couple nights and we found out I mean I
actually was googling this prior but
it's so funny because we found out on
the show from some cool fans that you
cannot buy oil for under like the dollar
thing like like the fact that way under
can't buy barrels of oil it even if we
watch it because we were thinking where
can we get barrels of crude oil can we
just store it in our backyard sick would
it be and we became [ __ ] oil barons
yeah during this whole situation and how
fun would it be if you're like at a
cocktail party somewhere and like yeah I
think 9/11 was an inside job also I'm in
oil bear yeah people would [ __ ] lose
a tycoon right is it cuz you guys don't
have the proper licenses or something I
just done all the right people to buy it
well there's no it sold
how you gonna get to you you have to
spend so much [ __ ] money to bring
those oil big barrels to your plate and
there's regulations like storing the
toxic and [ __ ] like that like you can't
just leave it in your backyard it's kind
of like the you know how the milk
producers recently we're dumping all of
the milk that they gallons and gallons
on
gallons of milk right because well the
milk was supposed to go towards schools
toward the restaurant and open so the
milk producers are just dumping it into
into the dirt can't do that with oil so
what are you gonna do with it you can't
just dump it out because you have too
much so now you're just paying people to
get about dump it in the ocean
do not be P so put it in the river
oh my god so that's what's wild about
this whole situation is that the the so
a lot of the conspiracy a lot of
conspiracy land is that oil has driven
most of our foreign policy in the past
like 40 50 years which really isn't that
much of a conspiracy for think about it
so the idea is that the fact that
there's no demand for it now is the most
ironic thing maybe ever that they did
all that posturing all that fighting all
that bloodshed thousands of Americans
dead in so many countries and now it's
like nobody wants well that's the that's
the right so the idea behind that is
that we went into these countries
because of oil because Iraq has well oil
tons of oil and we went in there and
then and then what's so funny is that we
all convinced ourselves that America
went into Iraq to give democracy to the
Iraqi people
we went there to freedom and from all
this [ __ ] but really we got there and
then our politicians sold the oil
contracts to China why a lot of those
people have also been busted like like
Dianne Feinstein in California for
having Chinese spies under their employ
mmm-hmm she had a driver for 35 years
who was like a [ __ ] Chinese spy it was
reported she wasn't careful right I mean
so who knows how much influence our
politicians have had with China over the
years I think so the idea that we have
had this independent democracy in China
does their thing we're at war with each
other is probably [ __ ] because we
got we get heavily influenced by Chinese
money Chinese money Saudi Arabia money
different lobbyist groups different
interest groups and when people say what
are these interest groups it's usually
corporations that have a special
interest that's why they're called
special interest
so like let's say you are a bunch of oil
companies and you want easier
regulations because you're spending
millions of dollars every [ __ ] year
because some guy has to come in and
check off some [ __ ] on a clipboard
because you know you might just get some
pelicans to die or whatever and that's
why we really awful the time about
corporatists capitalism crony capitalism
and not actual capitalism because we
don't have that here
like we have a crony capitalism where
the people at the top are literally paid
off and it goes all the way down the
chain and it depends it's not always the
same people so let's say sometimes it's
oil interest sometimes it's tobacco's
sometimes it's nations like China
sometimes it's nations with special
interests or corporations from other
countries like maybe you're up or
whatever let's say there's a special
interest group in the automobile
industry Germany maybe and BMW Mercedes
Volkswagen all those guys come in and
then they'll pay our politicians that'll
make laws in favor of their car
companies stuff like that and then don't
sell out our car companies or whatever
they catch out of Congress they leave
multi Multi multi millionaires and then
the net makes no sense they made a
couple hundred grand a year it makes
it's like I think Ron Paul is one of the
guys but they try to stop that after you
you're a career politician that there's
a limit of 5 to 10 years or something
after leaving office you can't have a
corporate job and I think that's a
genius yeah it is and it should be it
should be within everything because
these guys leave defense contractors
within are they they leave the defense
department they join defense contractors
like raytheon-sarcos and they all are
actually just working together in
collaboration the whole time that's the
jig yep
that's the end that's the
military-industrial complex everyone
likes to make fun of that and say like
all out Jones says that a lot so that's
silly but if you actually look at it the
military-industrial complex is the
realest [ __ ] maybe ever like ever
exposed by a president on States
Eisenhower said it it got carried
forward by JFK and then Trump actually
just accidentally said yeah I think
there's
how did he axis accidentally he is so
funny because I think he doesn't know
what to huh hold back and sometimes all
you just cares about is himself so he'll
say some [ __ ] his ego so big yeah you
like I know the secrets you guys don't
[ __ ] know right you know right I know
but dude bigs right so he'll sit there
and I saw him on a fox news interview
say I think military industrial complex
is like I think that's a good thing
that's like cuz he's like I try to pull
troops out and he's like and then it
won't let me they say you can do can't
do that I'm like okay which is so
fascinating cuz it's like wait you're
the president you are the buck stops
with you apparently but but then we all
know that the intelligence apparatus
those guys they last for 25-30 years
each they go across multiple
administration's they all agree on the
same [ __ ] policies so we live in a
[ __ ] we might as well be a
third-world country you know the United
States of America because what our
people get the people at the bottom and
the middle class what they get is [ __ ]
right and then the people at the top and
in Congress and who are connected to the
oligarchs of our country they all get
all the sick riches and all the cool
[ __ ] so that's why you have people on
cable news who get paid six salaries to
tell you why the government is right
about whatever is going on or why the
government you shouldn't really listen
the government right now because Trump
is in charge but ultimately we're gonna
support his entire agenda because that's
part of our agenda so we have a neo
conservative a neo liberal elite that
are running the country
and then the rest of us are just sort of
[ __ ] underneath it which is why you
all got $1,200 to last you six months
and you're not supposed to [ __ ] about
anything because you've got $1,200 so
what are you bitching about while Wall
Street got bailed out and they don't
give a [ __ ] if people are suffering no
they don't give a [ __ ] and they know
they're never going to jail for anything
because that's what happened last time
during the housing crisis nobody goes to
jail at the top the CEOs don't go to
jail nobody [ __ ] pays so how can we
take advantage of this oil crisis right
you can't invest into oil companies but
you got to figure out which ones will be
bailed out and which ones are gonna be
destroyed
like destroyed so take your 1200 our
Trump buck tech and play whack-a-mole I
sure hope you get the right old company
[Music]
it's bleak like George Carlin said it's
a big [ __ ] party and you're not in it
yup
[Music]
[Music]